there are a lot of different ways to
make a good burger at home i think it's
important all parts of the recipe fit
together
and complement each other because of
this i think it can be helpful to put
burgers into two main categories thick
patty burgers
and thin patty ones they call for
different techniques
and even ingredients to illustrate this
i'm going to go through two different
cheeseburger recipes one thin
one thick both pretty basic let's start
with thin for the thin patty burger i'm
making a slider with just a few
less expensive ingredients first thing
is slicing up some white onion
uh pretty thin for the bread i'm using
hawaiian rolls
they're very sweet and very soft i used
two rolls still stuck together and
sliced that in half
for me i'm just using regular ground
beef that is 80 20
so 80 lean beef and 20 fat
you want a good amount of fat so you
don't end up with a dry flavorless
burger i'm using
an eighth of a pound which is about 55
grams
it's probably best to grind your own
meat but we'll get to that later for now
i'm just using standard stuff from the
grocery store a really popular technique
for making thin patty burgers is to
smash them
making it a smash burger when done right
like this one from burgers never say die
they're great but really doing them well
at home can be difficult
you need the right tools and if you're
using a spatula the edges of the pan can
get in the way and even with two metal
spatulas it can be tough to apply enough
force to get it to smash down quickly
and form that special crust
so when i cook at home i just flatten
the meat before i cook using some wax
paper
and my hands then salt and pepper since
the patty is so thin you really only
need to do one side
i'm using cast iron because it retains
heat well which is good for getting a
nice crust
i start with the pan preheated i put
some butter down and place the sliced
onions on top because we want them to
caramelize a little
then i put on the patty it doesn't take
very long to cook only a minute or so
once flipped i add the cheese i use
american cheese because it melts really
fast which is great for this and i think
it tastes good then i have the buns i
kind of mop up some of the fat from the
burger to help toast them up
adding water and covering helps melt the
cheese faster and it steams the bun i
usually do this for about 30 seconds
then i kind of shove the onions
on top of the melted cheese so i can
just pull it off all in one thing
that's all there is to it really just
four ingredients plus salt pepper and
butter
mustard or pickles would be a good
addition but i don't think they're
necessary and it really doesn't need
ketchup since the bun and the onions are
both sweet
you can definitely use a different
cheese but it can be tough to melt it
fast enough
not to overcook the burger next up is
the thick patty
for the bread i wouldn't use hawaiian
rolls since they're so soft and don't
really hold up to the weight of a thick
patty even most grocery store buns like
this potato one
are a bit too soft for this so i'm using
this fancy bun i got at this place that
makes them specifically for their own
burgers it has the structure i'm looking
for
and holds up to everything else for
cheese i'm using cheddar this is a
regular cheddar but i like really sharp
cheddar as well
you want a good thick slice to balance
things out and since the burger is going
to cook longer
you can have a cheese that takes longer
to melt and use a larger amount of it
too
this slice is about 40 grams i'm going
to do onions on this burger as well
this time a red onion making thicker
slices to get these rings which will go
on raw for some crunch
now for this burger a sauce is really
going to help balance everything out
with the extra bread and meat this is
your standard burger sauce
mainly ketchup and mayo except i'm gonna
make the mayonnaise from scratch
and mince one or two cloves of garlic
this one's pretty big so i'm just doing
one
next some pickles i like cutting up
whole pickles because i find relish is
usually too sweet and since i'm adding
ketchup to the sauce it really doesn't
need that
plus i can control the size of the
chunks and i like to leave them a bit
bigger so in a large bowl i do one egg
yolk the garlic i minced a bit of
whatever mustard you want and some lemon
juice but just a little because we're
gonna add more later
i whisk this and then start adding a
little bit of olive oil at a time
i'm going really slow to make sure to
not add too much and break the mixture
i like to start with olive oil for
flavor but then after a bit i switched
to a more neutral oil
like this vegetable oil i keep going
little by little making sure the oil is
fully incorporated before adding more
this can definitely go wrong if you add
too much oil at once it will break apart
or just stay thin and never thicken if
it does go right it should get thick
like this
now i'll add some more lemon juice for
flavor which also thins it out a bit
i'll even add a bit of water if it's
still too thick but don't want more of
the lemon
you can salt to taste and stop right
here and you just have a nice garlic
mayo
i like using this for blt's or to dip
potato wedges in but since this is going
to be a burger sauce
in go the pickles i cut up and some
ketchup you can do as much as you want
i don't like adding too much this is
about a tablespoon this adds a bit of
sweetness umami
and some color i like to make the sauce
first and then keep it in the fridge
because it tastes better after sitting a
while
for me the whole point of having a thick
patty is to be able to achieve a good
crust on the outside while still
maintaining a medium rare center
where you can really taste the flavor
and texture of the beef
since i want a medium rare center i
really want good high quality ground
beef
i'm using this freshly ground stuff from
a local butcher that specializes in
australian wagyu and dry aged steaks but
you can always grind your own
buy some chunks of beef chuck works
tasty and others recommend a mixture of
chuck
sirloin and short rib cut it into small
cubes put that in the freezer for about
20 minutes to get it cold and firm
this helps the meat grind properly and
not turn into a paste
then you use a grinder that you also
kept in the freezer so that's cold as
well and you just grind it all
up and then this trick of weighing and
forming the patties like this from how
they do it at gramercy tavern for their
burger
it makes it really easy and it gives the
burger straight sides and sharp edges
which i think looks nice but if you're
not into
that you can just form the patty by hand
salt and pepper both sides
i'm toasting the buns with some butter
before i cook the burger so they're
ready to go once the burger's done
i put the sauce just on the top bun some
people are really intense about putting
something
under the patty to protect the bottom
bun from getting soggy but i haven't had
any issues with that i think if you're
going to eat it straight away it
shouldn't be an issue
i'm on medium high for the patty about
three or four minutes
and then flip add the cheese i'm doing a
bit of water and covering it again
to help melt the cheese i go another
three or four minutes on this side
aiming for medium rare you could
definitely add something green or some
tomatoes if you like
i do think with such a large burger it
can get unwieldy if you have too much
additional stuff
even with just these onions in the sauce
it's a little precarious
does really help to have some things to
balance out the beef an egg on top can
be a nice addition
hiano founder of joconi has a spicy
tomato jam recipe that's great on
burgers
you could do entirely different
ingredient sets too
like a chili cheeseburger or a combo of
blue cheese caramelized onions and
arugula
so thick patty versus thin patty both
are great but you really get something
quite different with each and as long as
you're aiming for
what makes each best you should be good
[Music]
you